[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا وهذه نشره التاسعه هذا
المساء نبدا بالعناوين
الرئيس الصيني يصل السعوديه في زياره
رسميه تركز على زياده التعادل ويشارك في
ثلاث قمم
[موسيقى]
المانيا تشهد محاوله انقلاب من جماعه
الرايخ اليمنيه والمتورثون قاضيه وعسكريون
سابقون
التهديد بوقوع حرب النوويه مرتفع جدا
ومسكت تمتلك واسلحه متطوره
الاحتجاجات في ايران على نحو المتصاعد
والاضرابات تتسع لتشمل اكثر من 50 مدينه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه مشاهدينا من السعوديه
حيث وصل الرئيس السوري
الى المملكه بدعوه من خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز ال
سعود وكان في استقبال الرئيس الصيني في
مطار الملك خالد الدولي امير منطقه الرياض
الامير فيصل بن بندر بن عبد العزيز ووزير
الخارجيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
[موسيقى]
اشاركه الاستراتيجيه التي بنيت بين
السعوديه والصين على مدى عقود هي دعامه
اساسيه بني عليها تعاون اقتصادي المشترك
وتبادلات تجاريه واستثمارات لتصبح الصين
في السنوات الاخيره شريكه التجاريه الاول
للمملكه
ارقام بالمليارات وحصص وزنا عجزت سلم
الاستثمارات والتبادل التجاري بين الرياض
وبكينا فالصين تحولت لشركه تجاريا اول
للسعوديه في السنوات الخمس الاخيره مشكله
الوجه الاولى لصادرات المملكه ووالداتها
منذ عام 2018 حيث بلغ حجم التجاره بين
البلدين العام الماضي اكثر من 300 مليار
رياله اي بزياده قدرها 39% عن عام 2020
وفاق اجمالي حجم الصادرات السعوديه للصين
190 مليار ريال منها صادرات غير نفطيه
بقيمه واحد واربعين ملياريه في ميزان
الذهب الاسود تميل السعوديه اكبر مصدر الا
بكينا لا سيما مع ارتفاع الواردات الصينيه
من السعوديه بنسبه ثلاثه فاصل واحد في
المئه مقارنه بعام 2020 اما قيمه
استثمارات المملكه في الصين فتصل الى
النيه مليارات و600 مليون ريال ما وضعها
بالمرتبه الثانيه عشره في ترتيب الدول
المستثمره هناك حتى نهايه عام 2019 في
المقابل تستحوذ السعوديه على اكثر من 20%
من استثمارات الصين في العالم العربي
بنهايه العام الماضي اي ما قيمته 39 مليار
دولار وفي هذا الاطار وضعت شركه صينيه عدى
بينها تشينغ كونغ حجر الاساسي لمصانع
بمناطق سعوديه عده فيما تمثل الشركات اخرى
كشركه ينبع ارامكو وسانوبيك للتكرير
نموذجا للشركات الاستثماريه المتزايده بين
البلدين مشروع لزياده التعاون النووي
وصندوق تمويل المشترك وعضويه تكتلات
الاقتصاديه دوليه وغيرها محطات على طريق
النوامه بين رؤيه 2030 ومبادره الحزام
والطريقه
[موسيقى]
انتقل الان مشاهدينا الى زميل الليالي
اختيار في الرياض لمتابعه مجريات هذه
الزياره اليك ليال مساء الخير
شكرا لك ميسون مساء الخير مشاهدينا الى
هذه التغطيه للعربيه من الرياض للقمم
الصينيه الثلاثه التي ستبدا وبدات مع وصول
الرئيس الصيني وستكون تباعا على مدى
الايام الثلاثه المقبله معي هنا بالستوديو
الصحافي الصيني اهلا وسهلا بك وايضا صحفي
جاسر جاسر اهلا وسهلا بكم سابدا معكم
استاذ جاسر اليوم السعوديه باهميتها
الجيوستراتيجيه والصين باهميتها
الجيوبوليستيكيه كيف يمكن ان يسهم تعميق
العلاقه بين هذين هاتين الدولتين بتغيير
المعادلات الاقليميه
مساء الخير طبعا العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه
لها شكل مختلف منذ البدايه قائمه على شكل
متين من الموثوقيه من خلال تجارب السابق
من خلال يعني تريد الطاقه من السعوديه الى
الصين كان هناك دائما التزام ثابت
وبالتالي هذا عامل كم مهم ايضا في مشاريع
التنميه الصينيه في المقابل كانت تعامل
الدبلتين كانت تتعاملان بشكل مختلف قائم
على التنميه لم يكن هناك اشكالات سياسيه
لم يكن هناك صعوبات لم يكن هناك تحذبات او
تحالفات تحمل بشكل واضح كل الدوله لديها
خطه تنويه معينه تعمل عليها ولذلك اليوم
المملكه المستقبل الرئيس الصيني في هذه
الدعوه الموجهه الملكيه لتقوم على بناء
وتاسيس هذه العلاقه الى امل
تعميق هذه العلاقه بتحقيق اهداف المملكه
الاستراتيجيه للمرحله المقبله خصوصا اننا
امام رؤيه 2030 واهداف واضحه للمرحله
المقبله هو اللي يعني رؤيه المملكه 2030
خريطه واضحه ومكشوفه وبالتالي المملكه
تسير عليها بشكل اساسي
وتبحث مع الدول او الشركاء اين يمكن ان
يساهم ويكونوا شركاء في هذا الجانب ولذلك
جزء من التكتيك الذي تم الانشاء لجنه
الاستراتيجيه سعود الصينيه برئاسه الامير
محمد ونائب رئيس الدوله تالي هذه على
مستوى تعمل على خلق هذه الفرص والعمل
عليها القمه التي ستعقد غدا القمه
السعوديه الصينيه هي تقريبا جهود العمل
المتحقق قائم الاتفاقات المعموله هي صفقات
سننظر الى النتائج المتحقه وهي النتائج
ليست يعني مرحله او جزئيه لا هي تخطيط
للمستقبل المشترك على السنوات
استاذ ليه يعني العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه
بدات منذ زمن منذ العام 1939 قطعت بمراحل
متعدده
وعمقت بالفتره الماضيه الا ان التبادل
التجاري والتعامل التجاري سبق التعامل
الدبلوماسي بسنوات اليوم تعزيز هذه
العلاقات دبلوماسيه اقتصاديا سياسيا كيف
يمكن ان يخدم التوجه العالمي بعد يعني
انتهاء النظام العالمي القديم
يعني شكرا جزيلا الان تتكلم عن انتهاء
النظام العالمي القديم ولكن هناك حاجه
للعلم همم النظام العالمي الاكثر عداله
ومساواه وهذا ما يسعى اليه كل من الصين
وطول العربيه بما فيها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وبالتالي شيء كما تفضل لدينا من
همم
السعودي صح نعم بالنسبه الى الثقه
المتبادله وخصوص الثقه
السياسي المتبادله البلدين وبين الصيني
ودول عربيه بشكل عام يعني هذا مهم جدا
بالنسبه الى الكلى الجانبين وخاصه في الظل
التحديات المشتركه مهما كانت من منطقه
الشرق الاوسط او فيما يخص بالصين في منطقه
اسيا شرق اسيا فهذا مهم جدا وخصوصا يعني
هناك همم القيم المشترك وفي نفس الوقت
يعني زي ما تفضل ضيفنا العربي هناك
الاحترام لهذه القيم الخاصه لكل الجانبين
يعني ما يميز همم العلاقه الصينيه مع
الدول العربيه وعدم تدخلها بالسياسات
الدول الاخرى وهو تدخل يعني نهج واضح
بالسياسه الخارجيه ولكن اليوم تطوير
العلاقات الاقتصاديه السياسيه ديبلوماسيا
بين البلدين ساهما الى توجه شرقي للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه لتحقيق توازن اقليمي
وعالمي وتوجه غربي للصين للتحقيق ايضا
توازن شرق او سطئ وعلمي التوجهين كيف يمكن
ان يختو ماء اليوم علاقات البلدين انا
اعتقد في جانبي ما احب اسميها توجه شرقي
لانه المملكه تقوم على التنوع وبالتالي
على اختيار الفرص المناسبه والاستثمار لكن
في هذا الجانب اليوم احنا عندنا المسارين
التنميه والاستقرار المملكه تعمل على
التنميه والسين بتعمل على التنميه لكن
ايضا حتى تستمر التنميه وتحدث بشكل لابد
ان يكون هناك استقرار وهذا الاستقرار يجب
ان تكون هناك مساهمه ايضا من جانب الصين
في التحقيق وفي هذا الملف التعاون هذا
الاقتصادي وهذا الضخ الاقتصادي وهذه
المشاريع المشتركه والاتفاقات والعمل
اليوم يعني لك تم الاعلان عن انشاء يعني
مركز اقليمي للمصانع الصينيه في المملكه
كله فبالتالي ان المملكه حينما المملكه
بسيطه المملكه
الصين والخليج همم الدول العربيه والصين
اذا هي بناءات قائمه على المستقبل بمعنى
ان الصين شريط اقتصادي ثابت وداعم ومستمر
للمستقبل وبالتالي في الاختبارات
وايضا يعني في المقابل الجانب الاخر المهم
انه هناك بناء سلسله شراكات يعني الوحده
الخليجيه تمضي ككتله اقتصاديه وسياسيا ثم
تاتي الوحده العا- المجموعه العربيه في
المملكه هناك ثلاث دوائر للتنميه المملكه
الخليج العربي هذه الدوائر الحميميه
الثابته لتامر على المملكه ولذلك استقطاب
الصين اشتراك هو يتجاوز كل هذه الجوانب
والعمل
ماذا ينعكس يعني عكس اعتقد في جوانب الدعم
السياسي الصيني لمساهمه في تحقيق
الاستقرار وبالتالي التقارب بشكل اكثر في
الملفات السياسيه التي تؤدي او تغرق او
تؤذي». اليوم من المعلومه ان المملكه
بتوجهها ان كان الاقتصادي ان كان السياسي
ان كان الديب هو قائم على التنوع كما قال
دكتور جاسر وبالتالي لن تذهب الى محور
امام محور اخر هل الصين وعيا لهذا الموضوع
وهل يمكن تجنيد يعني تبعات الحرب البارده
بينكم وبين الامريكيين للمنطقه طبعا طبعا
لماذا زار الفخامه الرئيس الصيني الى
المملكه وبعد المؤتمر الوطني العشرين على
حسب الشعيريه الصيني هذا اول دوله عربيه
واول دوله في الشرق الاوسط تكون رئيسه
فخامه الرئيس يقوم فخامه الرئيس الصيني في
زياره اليها ثم ثاني شيء بنسبه الى
التوجه او نقول التنوي همم السياسات
الخارجيه او سياسات او الاقتصاد في
الحقيقه يعني عند الصين النفس الرؤيا مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لا قضايا مثل عقارات مثل ال- ال- ال- ال-
التصدير يعني هناك همم من الممكن نقول
هناك تبادل التي تنميه الاقتصاد الفلسطيني
لذلك يعني مع ان هناك العلاجات متينه
وخصوصا في التجاره همم النفط وايضا الطاقه
المتجدده مع مبادرات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في السعوديه لا خضراء وايضا
الشرق الاوسط الاخضر يعني هناك المجالات
اوس عليك تعون العلاوه عن المجالات
القديمه دكتور جاسر اليوم هناك مشروع نهضه
للمملكه بالمنطقه وبالعالم هذا المشروع
النهضه النموذج الصيني الذي يمكن وصفه
بالفريق لانه اليوم يعني يد مش بين
الراسماليه بين الشيوعيه او الاشتراكيه
هذا النموذج كيف يمكن ان يخدم المشروع
النهضوي في الفتره المقبله وكيف يمكن
تطوير هذه العلاقات وخصوصا الاقتصاد هو
الاساس فيه
على انها دوله مستقله بعيدا عن التحجبات
الهيدروجينيه والولاءات المستقيمه على
المنفعه وما يخدم المملكه وما يحقق رؤيه
المملكه
ولماذا تضل الصين احد اهم شركاء واكثرهم
موثوقيه في هذا الجانب اللي هو قيمه ان
الصين تكوينها قائمه على التنميه ايضا
وبعيدا عن التجاذب السياسيه لحد يعني نرى
السين كثيرا في كثير من الملفات في
التجاذبات السياسيه ولا هذا الجانب مهم
لانه يغذي الراغب المشتركه عند الطرفين
وبالتالي همم تتحول هذه القوه اللي القوه
الاقتصاديه الى قوه ايضا قائمه على نوع من
الجوانب المهمه اللي هي الشركات الثقافيه
ونفس العقيقه بدون متباعده في الظاهر لكن
هناك الروح شرقيه تجمع هذه الثقافات في
نطاق واحد وهذه المساله ليست متصله فقط
بالتعاملات التجاريه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
هي قائمه على قيم اخلاقيه معينه تشترك بين
هذه الدول تكون اساس لكل النشاطات
المستقبليه استاذ لي اليوم يعني من
المعلوم ان حاله المساكنه بين الراسماليه
والشروعيه يقول الامريكيين بانها انتهت
وهم بداوا منذ فتره بما يعرض بالحرب
البارد او ضدكم مع دخول الصين بهذه
المرحله الجديده ومع سعي الصين الى
الاكمال بسياسه الانفتاح العالمي وخصوصا
على دول الشرق الاوسط كيف يمكن ان تطمئن
هذه الدول ان يعني السياسه هي طويله الامل
وستؤسس لمرحله نهوض مشترك بينكم نعم في
الحقيقه انا ارى ان تحركات ليس وحاديه
الجانب من صيني او من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او من دول العربيه بس هذه تحركات
تحركات ثنائيه همم الجهه لذلك يعني بنسبه
الى الصين فهمم زي ما قلت عليه هناك في
التعاون في تعزيز تعاون في طاقه التقليديه
وايضا في طاقه جديده ومن جانب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بشكل خاص او
بدول العربيه هناك حاجه او هناك
في تعزيز البوني لتحتيه مهما كان في
القطار او المطارات او المشاريع الكبرى
مثلا هناك كثير من الشركات يساهم في تنميه
مدينه نيوم مشروع نيوم في المملكه و
بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني اريد ان اشير الى
هناك نقطه مهمه جدا علاوتها عن التعاون
الاقتصادي
فحتى بمكافحه الجايه حتى الكرونه هناك
تعاون عميقه بين الصين ودول العربيه
وبمثابتها المملكه العربيه السعوديه فخادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان هو الاول
منها قيادات الدول العربيه همم عبره عن
دعمه لسعد الصيني وايضا فخامه الرئيس
الصيني
وفي الحقيقه هناك دعم كبيره ماليا وايضا
روحيا من الجانب السعودي الى الصين في
مواجهه لذلك يعني من الممكن نقول التعاون
ليس فقط بالاتصال او باتجاره او في سياسه
حتى عسكري بل يعني اهم شيء الانسانيه
وهذا يعني من ضمن مبادراتها ولي العهد
صاحب سمو الامير محمود بن سلمان في
الاندماج اللغه الصينيه فتعليم في نظام
تعليم المملكه وهذا مهم جدا
شكرا لكم ضيوف استاذ جاسر جاسر والصحافي
الهاملي شكرا لكم على وجودكم هنا مشاهدينا
ساعود الى دبي والى الزميله ميسون ميسون
عوده اليك طبعا سنتابع تغطيه هذه القمه
مشاهدينا غدا وبعد غد ايضا
بمقابلات من الرياض بموازات القمم التي
ستعقد غدا وبعد غد اليك ميسون شكرا يعني
مشاهدينا قالت المتحدثه باسمي وزاره
الخارجيه الصينيه مونينجا ان زياره الرئيس
السني للسعوديه وعقد قمتين مع السعوديه
والخليج يعدو اكبر عمل دبلوماسي في علاقات
الصين مع العالم العربي
في الوقت الراهن بالتزامن مع التغيرات
العالميه
والوفاء الذي لم نشهده منذ قرن العالم
نعود ونذكر مشاهدينا بابرز ما تحدث به
الرئيس الصيني منذ وصوله الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه قال بانه سيبحث مع الملك
سلمان وولي العهد التعاون الثنائي
والقضايا الدوليه والاقليميه ايضا الرئيس
الصيني تحدث بان التعاون العملي مع
السعوديه اسفر عن نتائج مثمره في كافه
المجالات ايضا قال هناك ثقه استراتيجيه
متبادله مع السعوديه وبشكل مستمر كما ذكر
بان الصين تربطها بالسعوديه علاقه وثيقه
من الصداقه والشركه هذا ابرز ما تحدث عنه
الرئيس الصيني منذ وصوله الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه خلال هذه الزياره وخلال
القمم الثلاثه التي ستعقد في اليومين
المقبلين في المملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا
المشاهدين مرحله تطوير للتماشي مع تغيرات
العصر وموائمه البلدين دخلتها العلاقات
السعوديه الصينيه علما بان هذه العلاقات
مبنيه على اكثر من 70 عاما من التعاون
والتنسيق واشترك الاستراتيجيه في كافه
المجلات
استقبال حجاجا وتجارات بسيطه جذور بنيت
عليها العلاقات السعوديه الصينيه الممتده
منذ 77 عاما
العلاقات التي ابتسمت ببساطه اوليه اتخذت
شكلها الرسمي قبل 32 عاما بعد اتفاق
البلدين على اقامه علاقات دبلوماسيه كامله
وتبادل السفراء وتنظيم اجتماعات على
مستويات سياسيه واقتصاديه وغيرها
[تصفيق]
محطات عده تبعت هذه المرحله كتشكيل لجنه
سعوديه صينيه مشتركه عام 2004 برئاسه وزير
خارجيه البلدين والاتفاق على بدء حوارا
سياسيا منتظمه تبعها الاعلان عن اقامه
علاقات الصداقه الاستراتيجيه عام 2008
من محطاتها كذلك زيارتان للملك سلمان بن
عبد العزيز اولها في عام 99 حين كان اميرا
لمنطقه الرياض اما الثانيها في عام 2014
كوليا للعهد وكانت تاكيد مجددا على
اعتزازه بمستوى العلاقات الثنائيه التي
تشمل مختلف اوجه التعاون المشتركه
وما بينها زيارات لرؤساء الصينيين للمملكه
ملفاتها مره اخرى شملت التشديد على
التعاون والتشاور والتنسيق سعيا لتعزيز
السلم والامن اقليميا ودوليا
وهنا المواقف ثابته عند ضروره ايجاد تسويه
سياسيه عاجله للمساله السوريه ووحده اليمن
وسيادته
من دوليه لقاءات لولي العهد الامير محمد
بن سلمان بالرئيس الصينيه احدها في قمه
دول مجموعه العشرين بالارجنتين عام 2018
عقبها بزياره الى بكين في العام التالي
حرص على تبادل الزيارات رفيعه المستوى غزه
ومجموعه التفاهمات بالمجلات الاقتصاديه
تذهب باتجاه المواكمه بين مبادره الحزام
والطريق ورؤيه 2030 فالسعوديه الشريك
الرئيسي للجمهوريه الشعبيه في المنطقه
مسؤولينا سينين
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء سنتابع بعد قليل
بعض النفط الاتحاد الاوروبي
سعر الغاز الروسيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نفذ الف من رجال الشرطه
الالمانيه اليوم الاربعاء سلسله
كما انهم يرفضون شرعيه الجمهوريه
الالمانيه الحديثه المدعي العام الالماني
اكد ان الجناح العسكري للمنظمه الانقلابيه
كان يهدف لبناء الجيش المانيا الجديد
كاشفا ان بعض المنتمين المنظمه الانقلابيه
كانوا ناشطين في الجيش الالماني
منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
والانقلابات العسكريه لا تعرف طريقا الى
اوروبا
العام وسلطات الالمانيه تلقي القبض على
عده اشخاص في مداهمات شملت انحاء البلاد
يشتبه بتامرهم للاطاحه بالحكومه حيث صنف
الادعاء الالماني تلك المحاوله بالانقلاب
على السلطه وان المعتقلين يعتقد انهم شكل
العام الماضي منظمه ارهابيه بهدف قلب نظام
الدوله الحالي في المانيا
واستبداله بنظام خاص بهم فيما تشير تقارير
المانيه الى ان مجموعه من الشخصيات
العسكريه السابقه اليمنيه خطاطه الاقتحام
مبنى البرلمان والاستيلاء على السلطه
الاف شرطي نفذ عمليات تفتيش في 130 موقعا
داخل
10 من اصل 16 ولايه المانيه اسفرت عن
اعتقال 25 شخصا من افراد مجموعه يمنيه
ارهابيه
القبض طال ايضا مواطنين روسا الامر الذي
دفع سفاره الروسيه في برلين بالمصارعه الى
نفي علاقتها مع هذه المجموعه
موسكو لم تكتفي بنفي سفارتها بلتبع الامر
تصريحات الكرملين التي اعلنت ان المداهمات
الجاريه في المانيا شان داخلي والا علاقه
لروسيا بها
المداهمات وهي عمليه لمكافحه الارهاب
المشتبه بهم ربما خط طول شني هجمات مسلحه
تستهدف مؤسسات الدوله
مداهمات اعتقالات واسلحه ظبطت مع
المعتقلين يتم استخدامها في الجيش
الالماني فيما تفيد تقارير المانيه ان
عسكريين سابقين هم ايضا جزء مهم من مؤامره
الانقلاب هذه وبينهم جنود نخبه سابقون من
الوحدات الخاصه
[موسيقى]
من العنف والجريمه ارتكبتها مجموعات واقفل
يمين في المانيا وبتت تشكل خطرا ارهابيا
على البلاد برمتها هناك اكثر من
24,000 شخص ينتمون الى هذه المجموعه داخل
المانيا
13000 منهم يميلون للعنف وهذا ما تقوله
الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه التي
بدورها تراقب حركه هذه المجموعات التي
تنشط في بعض الدول الاوروبيه والمعروفه
بعدائها للمهاجرين والمسلمين الحركه
ارتكبت 100
واربعه 10 جريمه في المانيا خلال عام واحد
فقط ما بين عام 2017 و 2018
نشاط وعنف واقصى اليمين يتركز دائما في
شرق المانيا فمثلا عام 2014 ارتكب عناصر
واقصى اليمين 47 اعتداءا وكان بدفع عنصريه
في شرق المانيا على الرغم من ان عدد
السكان فيها لا يشكل سوى 17% من اجمالي
سكان البلاد نتابع
[موسيقى]
المنظمه تضمه اعضاء الناس
تدير اعمالها من خلال مجموعات صغيره عبر
شبكه الانترنت ومن المعروف ان المنظمه
تمتلك كميات كبيره من الاسلحه تقوم
بعمليات ضد قوات الامن الالمانيه وزير
الداخليه الالمانيه كان كشف ان هناك 50
شخصا من اقصى اليمين يشكلون خطرا كبيرا
وهم تحت المراقبه برلين حضاره العديد من
التنظيمات والمجموعات المؤيده لاقصى
اليمين في المانيا الا ان اغلبها لا يزال
يمارس انشطته المعديه هذه المنظمه التي
يراقبها جهاز حمايه الدستور لا تعترف
بالجمهوريه الفدراليه الالمانيه ولا ايضا
بدوله القانونه ولافت ان هذه المجموعات
تمارستها عبر احزاب سياسيه منها البديل من
اجل المانيا بديل الشباب والحزب الوطني
الديمقراطي الالماني وغيرها من الاحزان
[موسيقى]
من بالليل
اهلا بك معنا حيثيات هذه المداهمات
والاعتقالات ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل
اهلا بك يا ميسون يعني تم اعتقال 25 شخص
ولكن المستهدفين كانوا اكثر من ذلك قربت
الاثنين وخمسين شخص ربما ابرز ما يمكن
يعني تلخيصه في هذه العمليه بانها كشفت
فعلا مدى استمرار تغلغل اليمين المتطرف
المؤسسات العامه في المانيا لانه احد يعني
قاده ربما هذه المجموعه هي كانت تشغل الان
منصب قاضيه في محكمه اقليميه في برلين
يعني اعلنا عن استقالتها بعد الظهر او
مساء بعد ان تم اعتقالها والكشف عن دورها
الذي لم يحدد في الواقع داخل هذه المجموعه
هي نفسها كانت عضو او ما زالت عضو في حزب
البديل لالمانيا وخدمات كنائبه في
البرلمان في البندق حتى العام 2021 ايضا
كشفت عن انه ااه اليمين المتطرف ما زال
متغلا داخل القوات الخاصه داخل الجيش
الالماني قبل بدع سنوات كانت هناك فضائح
كبيره لانه التسربت عدد من الاخبار عن تور
اعداد من الكرتون الخاصه في اا يعني
عمليات لليميل المتطرف وتامين سلاح لهم
وما الى ذلك وحينها كان هناك جدل كبير
وتمت المطالبه بان تحدث يعني اصلاحات داخل
هذا يعني داخل المؤسسات الامنيه ولكن على
ما يبدو هذا لم يحدث لذلك ايضا يعني هذه
النقطه ملفه مشاكسه يعني تتطور في الايام
المقبله سيكون هناك نقاش داخل الفندق حول
هذه النقطه تحديدا دعاء اليها حزب الخضر
تفضل ميسون هل تم الحديث عن الاجراءات
التي ستتخذ بحق هؤلاء ام لا حديث عن ذلك
حتى الان
13 شخص منهم ما زالوا قيد الاعتقال من
الذين يعني تم اعتقالهم من بينهم رئيس هذه
الخليه الذي تقول الادعاء بانه رئيس هذه
الخليه الشخص الذي تم اعتقاله في
فرانكفورت وهو من عائله من النبلاء
القدامى في المانيا
بريس كان يريد ان يكون رئيس الدوله يعني
في هذا التحضير للانقلاب الذي كان اراده
ارادوا تحضيره الان الذي سيحصل بانه سيبدا
توجيه التوام لهؤلاء الذين همم ما زالوا
قيد الاعتقال وستتم تحضير فهم اضافيه بحق
الذين اعتقلوا اغنيه سبيلهم همم
الان سيبحث في ما اذا كان يملك ادله كافيه
لتوجيه الطعم اليهم ومحاكمتهم بحسب الادله
التي تم رفعها اليوم في المداهمات وبحسب
الاستجواب الذي قاده المحقق كونان معهم
بعد اعتقالهم اشكرك راغده بهنا مراسات
العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
الى الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه رجعها
الرئيس الروسي لازم يفوتنا ان تكون
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
طويله الامعاء خطر التهديد بوقوع الحرب
النوويه بكى مرتفعا بوتن قال ان 150 الف
جنديا من الاحتياط لتحاق بما يدين القتال
في اوكرانيا واشار الى عدم الحاجه لعمليه
تعبئه عسكريه جديده في الوقت الراهن فتنات
بولندا
في غرب اوكرانيا واضاف الرئيس الروسي ايضا
ان بلاده لا تمتلك واسلحه تكتيكيه نوويه
خارج روسيا على عكس الولايات المتحده
فيما يتعلق بخطر الحرب النوويه مثل هذا
التهديد يتزايد لاكون صادقا ومع ذلك لدينا
استراتيجيه لاستخدام وسائل الدفاع واقصد
هنا اسلحه الدمار الشامل والاسلحه النوويه
وكلها خاضعه للعقيده النوويه الانتقاميه
اي عندما يتم استهدافنا سنردد
في ملف الموازين
سعر النفط يدرس الغرب تحديد سعر للغاز
لتكون الضربه اكثر وقعا وفعليا وفقا للسحف
الغربيه
فبحسب موقع يورو اكتيف بلجيكي فان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي تدرس احتمالا خفض سعر
الغاز الى 220 يورو لكل ميجا واتساب قرار
طبعا سيضاعف غضب روسيا والتي تدرس ثلاثه
خيارات مختلفه فيما يتعلق بكيفيه الرد على
فرد الغرب سقفا لسعر نفسها ولذي اعتمد عند
60 دولار العرب سابدا معقول الخيارات
الروسيه وهو فرض حضره شامل على بيع المفتي
للدول التي وافقت على هذه القيود حتى لو
قامت بشراء المواد الخام من روسيا ليس
بشكل مباشر وانا من خلال دول الوسيطه وفقا
لصحف روسيه
تركز وتراقب اذا ما كانت
دول الشراء سترسل النفط الروسيه الى عضو
من مجموعه السبع كمستلم نهائيا الخيار
الروسيه الثانيه هو حظر الصادرات موجب
عقود تتضمن شرطه سقفا سعريا بغض النظر عن
الدوله المستفيده اما الخيار الثالث فهو
اعتماد سعر قياسي اي تحديد الحد الاقصى
للحسم على النفط اورال الروسي قياسا الى
نفط بران وحظر البيع في حاله زياده الحسم
اما عن موعد التنفيذ قال نائب رئيس
الوزراء الروسيه الكزاندر نوفاك انا ليه
الرد على تحديد سقف اسعار النفط ستدخل حيز
التنفيذ في ديسمبر الحالي
[موسيقى]
في التاسعه هذا المساء نتابع بعد قليل
القمه العربيه الذي التي عقدت في عام 2002
على ضروره الالتزام بقرار القمه العربيه
عام 2002
[موسيقى]
نفتح الان الملف الايرانيين نقلت صحيفه
نيورك تايمز ان اكثر من 50 مدينه في ايران
تغلق محلاتها التجاريه في احد اكبر
الاضرابات العامه منذ عقود تشهدها ايران
الاضراب يتزامن مع الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في
الشوارع الايرانيه والممتده منذ سبتمبر
الماضي ضد النظام طهران وفقا الصحيحه
[تصفيق]
الاحتجاجات في ايران على نحو متصاعد
وانتقلت من الاحتجاج الى الاضرابات
المتسوقون وضجيجهم اختفوا من هذه الازقه
الضيقه في اسواق طهران فلا بقاله ولا جزار
ولا حتى صيدليات الا وحرصت على المشاركه
بتنفيذ قرار بدا شعبيا بامتياز
هذا المشهد وتكرر في اكثر من 50 مدينه
ايرانيه اغلقت تجارها ابواب محالهم ولا
بونداء دعوات المنصقه للاضراب لمده ثلاثه
ايام
الايرانيون الذين انتقلوا من الاحتجاج
ليلا من اسطح منازلهم خوفا من قمع الحرس
الثوري يضربون في وضع النهار ويعلنون
مواقفهم بمشاركه واسعه من الطبقه العامله
من كل الفئات
جعبه النظام من التهديد واساليب القمع
التي لجا اليها لاخافه الايرانيين يبدو
انها خلت فمن قتل ميداني واحكام الاعدام
الصادره عن قضاء النظام والسجن والسحلب
بالاضافه الى التحرش باطفال واغتصاب
لفتيات كلها اعمال كشف عنها نشاطها ومراكز
حقوقيه تحت عنوان جرائم ارتكبها النظام
ونددت بها مؤسسات حقوقيه دوليه ومحليه
والان يهدد النظام الغاء التراخيص
التجاريه واعتقالي اصحابها
احتجاجات الايرانيين ضد نظام طهران تختلف
عن سابقاتها هذه المره فهي الاطوال زمنا
كما تتميز بتحد يوصف بالكبير ورغم توقعات
خبراء ان تلك تظاهرات لن تسقط النظام
الحليب لانها تشكل هزه كبيره بحقه تنازلات
ابدا نظام مرغما على تقديمها في محاوله
الاحتواء الوضع الداخلي لكن الشارع يصفها
بتنازلات مخادعه
حنان المصري العربيه
[موسيقى]
ااذا المشاهدين يشكل الحارس السوري
الايراني اليد العسكريه والسياسيه للمرشد
الاعلى علي خمينائي المثيره للقلق وفق
تقرير نشارته مجله التايمل الامريكيه
الحرس الثوري الايراني تاسس عام
وادرجته واشنطن على قائمه الارهاب عام
2017 يمتلك هذا الكيان قوات بحريه وفضائيه
واستخباراتيه ولديها ايضا ترسانه صاروخيه
كبيره وترسانه من الطائرات من دون طيار
مصنوعه محليا ايضا تحت مسمى فيلق القدس
يشارك نحو 200 الف مسلح من خارج ايران اين
هم موزعين على دول العراق لبنان سوريا
واليمن ودائما وفقا لتقرير نشره موقع قوات
مشاه البحريه الامريكيه الان العد المحتمل
لعناصر الحرس قد يصل الى ثمانيه ملايين من
رجال ونساء او حتى نحو 10% من سكان ايران
تقول تايم ويشكك فيها محللون عسكريون
غربيون لكن القوه العسكريه الفعليه للحرس
هي اقل من ذلك بكثير كما يبدو حيث يشير
تقرير المعهد الامريكي للسلام نشر عام
2010 الى ان عدد قوات الحرس يصل الان الى
150,000 رجل مقسمين بين قوات بريه بحريه
وايضا جويه التقرير نقل عن القائد في
الحرس الثوري اللواء جعفر قوله انما يقرب
من
200,000 شاب من جميع انحاء الشرق الاوسط
تم تنظيمهم وتسليحهم تحت قياده في نقل
القدس اما المجله الامريكيه كشفت ايضا ان
عناصر الحرس هم
الحونه مغسول ادمغه ايدولوجيا ويمكن
تعبئتهم بسهوله وغالبا ما يتم توظيفهم في
السفارات والجمعيات وايضا المؤسسات
الدينيه وثقافيه
[موسيقى]
البحث الايراني دكتور حسن هاشميان دكتور
هاشميان اهلا بك معنا هذه الاضرابات التي
لم تشهدها ايران منذ عقود هل سيكون
تاثيرها اهم من الاحتجاجات المستمره منذ
سبتمبر الماضي
لها تاثير قوي بموازاه الحركه في الشارع
واعتقد ان وفقا الى الاحصائيات في المراكز
الرسميه في ايران يوميا الف مليار شومان
ضرر ياتي النظام من خلال هذه الاضطرابات
يعني اذا استمرت لمده طويله هذه الاضرابات
ستضرب قسم كبير من الموارد الماليه
المتعلقه بالنظام خاصه الموارد التي تدفع
الى المليشيات التي جاءت في تبريركم ولذلك
هذه ستؤثر بشكل كبير على تنظيم هذه
المجموعات الارهابيه وايضا تنظيم الحرس
والبسيج في الداخل
البيت
وهو على اللسان اخته وحتى ابنها نشرها على
تويتر الحارس الثوري تقول لهم انه القوا
السلاح قبل فوات الاوان هذا الامر على
ماذا يدلل
علي خامني ليس لديهم قاعده شعبيه حتى في
داخل اسرتي نهايه عن الشعب وعن باقي لطياف
الموجوده في المجتمع الايراني وهذا يعني
ان الوسيله المتبقيه لعلي خامنئي لمواجهه
الشعب الايراني هي المجموعات الحرس
والبسيج وسلاحهم ولذلك واحد من داخل بيت
علي خانني يشهد على هذه القضيه ويطالبهم
بال هذا السلاح للارض
هل من المعقول ان يلقوا سلاحهم على الارض
وخاصه الحارس الثوري والبسيج هل هذا
هذا ممكن يعني اذا ينظرون الى شخص من داخل
بيت عائله خامنه يتحدث عنهم بهذا الشكل
هذا يعني ان لا يوجد هناك مقبوليه لهذا
النظام ولا يوجد اعتراف
شعبي بهذا النظام وهم عليهم ان يخرجوا من
دائره اغسل الادمغه وعليهم ان ينتبهوا الى
الاوضاع وعليهم يعو بان يقفون الى جانب من
اي جانب من التاريخ ولذلك هذه تؤثر على
هؤلاء المجموعه والجسم من هذه المجموعه
وربما نشهد هناك تاكل عندما الان همم هذا
تاكل وهو واضح في صفوف الحرس شكرا لك
دكتور حسن هشام يعني
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه للعربيه شدد الرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس على ضروره الالتزام
بقرار القمه العربيه التي انعقدت عام 2002
وتضمنت مشروع الملك عبد الله باسم
المبادره العربيه للسلام
العربيه الذي التي عقدت في عام 2002
والتي قدم في ذلك الوقت
الله يرحمه الملك عبد الله
مشروعه اللي اسمه المبادره العربيه للسلام
المبادره العربيه للسلام تقول بالحرف
الواحد
احنا مع التطبيع شرط ان يبدا بفلسطين يعني
ياخذ الفلسطيني حقه ثم الباقي
نظيره التركي برفض قصف الاكراد في شمال
سوريا بدورها اكد منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي ان
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان ترى عمليات
عسكريه تجرى في شمال غرب سوريا قال في
تصريحاتنا العربيه ايضا انه لا يستطيع
حاليا تاكيد عوده العمليات العسكريه
الامريكيه في شمال سوريا مؤكدا ان
الاولويات في الوقت الراهن تظل للجهود
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
نحن ايضا سنبقى بملفات كاس العالم لكن
سنعود بها الى الذاكره وقصه مثيره جدا اذ
لم يكن هيكتور كاسترو في حاجه الى اكثر من
ذراع واحد للتتويج بلقب كاس العالم مع
منتخب اوروغواي تعود تفاصيل القصه الى
عشرينيات وثلاثنيات القرن الماضي تحديدا
النسخه الاولى للمونديال حين سجل هيكتور
كاسترو اول هدفا في تاريخ نهائيات كاس
العالم
الذي اصبح ملهما ذلك الوقت للشعب اوروغواي
بترت يده بمنشار كهربائي كان يستخدمه
لتقطيع الاشجار وهو كان في سن الثالثه عشر
من عمره ليفقد بذلك يده مدى الحياه لكنه
فقد يده لكن لم يفقد ايمانه وشغفه بكره
القدم اذا اصر حتى انضم الى نادي ناشونال
في اوروجواي الى ان سطع نجمه وتحقق حلمه
بالانضمام الى منتخب بلاده ثم قاده في اول
نسخه من المونديال والتي اقيمت ايضا في
الاورغواي وفي اول مباراه له في كاس
العالم افتتح صاحب اليد الواحده اهداف
منتخب اوروجواي في كاس العالم عبر التاريخ
بعد ما سجل في مرمى بيرو ليغيب بعدها عن
المبارتين التاليتين امام رومانيا ويوسفيا
السابقه في نصف النهائي اما في المباراه
النهائيه كانت النتيجه تشير الى تقدم
اوروغواي على الارجنتين بثلاثه اهداف
لاثنين وسط ضغط مكثف المنتخب التانجو من
اجل التعادل الا ان هيكتور كسترو سجل هدف
منتخب بلاده الرابع في الدقيقه التاسعه
والثمانين ليحسم الامور ويقود منتخب بلاده
الى تتويج باول نسخه من كاس العالم
وليثبت اسمه وقصته في تاريخ اللعبه
[موسيقى]
في مونديال هذا العام في قطر خرجت الغتره
والثوب العربيه عن الوانها المعتاده لتحمل
الوان مختلفه تعود لاعلام الدول التي
تشارك منتخباتها في مباريات كاس العالم
التفاصيل
الغتره والعقال والثوب اصبحت عنصرا هاما
في مونديال قطر 2022 فالكثير من مشجع
المنتخبات الوطنيه المشاركه في البطوله
العالميه يحاولون ابراز اعلام بلادهم من
خلال ما يرتدون من ازياء عربيه محليه منهم
من يرتدي الغتره العربيه بالوان منتخب
الارجنتين والبرازيل واسبانيا ومنهم من
يتجول في شوارع الدوحه وهو يرتدي ثوبا
مطرزا من الوان علم بلادها الاوروبيه
حملت هذه الازياء الوان اغلب المنتخبات
المشاركه في مونديال قطر وكل ما فاز منتخب
من مباراه تصفيات الكاس كل ما ارتفعت نسبه
بيع هذه الازياء الفريده وبامكان المشجع
البرازيلي او الفرنسي او الارجنتيني او
السعودي برفقه الجنسيات الاخرى التي
يتواجد منتخبها في المونديال شراء الزيئ
الذي يحمل الوان بلاده هذه المونديال
العربي يباع بسعر الرمزي لا يتعدى 99 ريال
قطريا ما يعادل سبعه وعشرين دولارا تقريبا
الامر الذي جعل الاقبال على الشراء من
اغلب الجماهير التي تتوافق على دوله قطر
لمتابعه مباريات كاس العالم التي تستمر
حتى الثامن عشر من ديسمبر 2022 لغايه
العربيه الدوحه دوله قطر
[موسيقى]
كشف موقع اكسيوس عن مخاطبات النواب
الجمهوريين داخل الكونجرس الامريكي لمختلف
الادارات الامريكيه لفتح تحقيق في
الانسحاب الامريكي من افغانستان هو ذكرت
ان هذه المخاطبات تساءلت عن كيفيه انشاء
جسر جوي للاجلاء من افغانستان على الرغم
من سيطره طالبان على مطار حامد كرزايه
وكذلك تساءلت عن خططه اعاده التوطين غير
المخطط لها للافغان الذين غادروا البلاد
وبحسبس فان النواب الجمهوريين يسعون لبدء
التحقيق في 20 23 بينما ياخذ البيت الابيض
هذا الحراك بشان التحقيق في انسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من افغانستان بجد
اعلنت اداره مكافحه الارهاب في الحرس
الوطني التونسي اليوم احباطن وخطه كان
يستهدف احدى الوحدات الامنيه ومؤسسه دينيه
بولايه صفاق السبع وقال المتحدث باسم
الاداره انه عنصر الارهابيين كان يستعد
لتنفيذ المخطط قبل احباطه في اطار عمليه
استباقيه وتحت اشراف النيابه العامه
انتهت نشره التاسعه هذا المساء نذكر
بالعناويننا
الرئيس الصيني يصل السعوديه في زياره
رسميه تركز على زياده التعاون ويشارك في
ثلاث قمم
المانيا تشهد محاوله انقلاب من جماعه
الريحي اليمنيه والمتورطون قاضيه وعسكريون
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الروسي محذرا تهديد بوقوع حرب
النوويه مرتفع جدا ومسكت تمتلك واسلحه
متطوره
في ايران على نحو المتساعد والاضرابات
تتسع لتشمل اكثر من 50 مدينه
انتهت نشرتنا ولكن نتابع ملفات جديده
واخبار عديده مع 360 مع راويه فضل لراويه
القمم السعوديه الخليجيه العربيه مع الصين
وايضا احباط محاوله الانقلاب في المانيا